greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by I had a mind yesterday during the
[ __ ] podcast people went nuts my
favorite underwears in the world me
undies me undies me undies as a podcast
fan you've heard me and every other
[ __ ] Mook talk on the microphone
about these [ __ ] bronze boxes and
briefs for years but here's the thing me
and these is the world's softest more
sustainable Underpants it's like having
an angel cradle you're nuts all day
every day when you rock and [ __ ] me
and these there's no sweat your balls
are [ __ ] nice and clean they smell
good they design their own the way for
comfort and self-expression whether you
go for the basic black brief or the
unicorn print you feel like a [ __ ]
King point is it's time to cut off your
toxic [ __ ] relationship with those
yellow [ __ ] underwears guys I know
you're hoarding some real [ __ ] skid
marks and you're drawing [ __ ] right that
will make the adult decision and get
yourself on a monthly plan for clean
fresh songs Gibby's you'll be delighted
with the monthly prints they offer for
members only
and you'll never have to settle for a
pair that embarrassed
[ __ ] [ __ ] ever again do me a favor
right now there's no brand especially
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee you get 15% off
your first pair free shipping and a
hundred percent guarantee go to me on
these comm slash Joey again go to me
undies dot-com slash Joey check this
[ __ ] me Olli
[Music]
welcome to church morning pops up
[Music]
nobody with this mask on my [ __ ]
guest tonight is my nephew from the
homeschool podcast the Agostino
[ __ ] enjoyed it good to see you
too man how's the family man I'm really
thankful everybody's really healthy we
got our health how's the podcast going
it's going good it's gonna need some
[ __ ] tips from me all right I want to
thank you for [ __ ] support in the
Comedy Store last night we had a great
time thank you very much for helping us
out uh that's my home like I said
yesterday on the pod thing is i'm mitzi
made I sent my money and today we're all
straight but I appreciate you guys
supporting us and even giving us a doll
or whatever the [ __ ] you have thank you
very much and that's it what's going on
D'Agostino man uh I'm doing what I can
I'm happy with this time that I have to
be honest with you you know I was
thinking of by the yard and I'm like I
bet you're happy you kept your day job
[Laughter]
listen there's a lot of guys man that
the thought of not having a day job just
petrified yeah you know and you got
married and things changed and you said
you know what I'm gonna keep my little
gig you still be a little spots doing a
week they let you travel you're right so
you got the world by the bull you know
well it's like we were saying before we
recorded that this is this is a
commission business you know I mean it's
just it's it's scary and I wasn't at a
place where I could rely only on it
you know and then like the plan always
was as little by little like the more
like I had dates the last hours I would
work and then eventually it would make
the shift over and I was getting like to
a point where I'm almost was about to go
to a part time before all this should
happen so now I'm thankful I have it I
know you're thankful so you talked about
the you know you're homeschooled this
[ __ ] yeah you know what's going on you
know it's a horror show yeah I never
thought I would be a principal of a
school yeah this has been a learning
experience for me and my wife you have
to learn how to be creative
between you and I think la school
district is doing a horrible
[ __ ] job just horrible like what we
don't know what to do camp got cancelled
for now yeah and this is rough on a
child I don't give a [ __ ] about me you
think they're doing a horrible job
before this and you were gonna pull her
out anyway
listen it's supposed to be the best
school in the district I don't want to
say to them but we moved into the
district so she'd go to that school
okay that's turned out it's like [ __ ]
you know we've settled on
I think we've lowered our standards as
Americans we really really have lowered
our standards things are so shitty that
we don't know what's good or what's not
good I know I have a ton of friends with
kids and they tell me about the schools
they go together and I just hear some
fantastic things I'm not - this is
[ __ ] okay this is [ __ ] yeah you
know she comes on at 11 o'clock she goes
to school from 10:00 to 10:30 and then
from 11:00 to like 11:45 the first half
hour was just kids yelling at each other
Marcus I got a purple shirt on you know
it's a [ __ ] nightmare yeah so you
know she's a racehorse she's seven so
you've gotta treat it like a [ __ ]
racehorse
you know you [ __ ] around with her you
don't get our exercise you're gonna find
yourself in a [ __ ] dilemma at eight
o'clock that's a horror show she so you
know like you know this time she's like
that you have to lunch you want to draw
a picture my dear dog
well I'm putting the last fork in my
mouth she's right there I turned in a
heads right there but what the [ __ ]
you know I understand so but this has
been a learning experience like we are
know what to do you first of all you
don't run her before that class comes on
you're gonna have a problem and I told
my wife I go this is what's going on
here
what the [ __ ] is the problem here this
is common sense when we drop her off at
school at 8 o'clock you don't go to work
the class right they run around for 20
minutes they don't get the IATA burn
their energy up then they sit down then
they write their journal then they [ __ ]
and learn whatever the [ __ ] it is and
you pick them up at 2:30 which is
[ __ ] - I want the school till 3:00
thirty yeah what the [ __ ] so no it's
like I gotta get up early with it but
the online class starts at 11:00 ten
o'clock for 30 minutes 25 minutes
Language Arts but they're giving you
that time to runner first before you go
online Oh what the [ __ ] school starts at
8:00 what the [ __ ] we don't depend yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on here yeah yeah
why does it start so yeah [ __ ] 11
o'clock
why wouldn't they start the same exact
time no for half-hour later no [ __ ]
idea and it's driving me crazy look at
the bags on my eyes it's driving me
[ __ ] crazy yeah that they have taken
this like a [ __ ] joke like I don't
take her education as a joke so now it's
like 10 o'clock 11 o'clock I come home
at 12:00 when I got it I think she's my
ghost yeah she's like a shadow and I
love her to death I love it a death but
it's like it's [ __ ] with her yeah you
know today we bailed out because other
kids called her we've set up calls with
other kids FaceTime and they have
messenger whatever the [ __ ] they yell
and they scream but if we don't have
that throughout the day it's a nightmare
you know because she's talking to you
they have their own language she's about
seven girls you know they have their own
pace they have your own [ __ ] language
you know she'll tell you a story for 30
minutes or you know yeah drop it on me
yeah so I got a runner in the morning
then you got a little language arts and
they do math and then you know what do
you do from Kovac Lockhart
you can't be playing so I try to call
her with her my wife doesn't you know I
gotta get my wife a [ __ ] breathe it -
yeah my wife goes out for a little walk
takes a ride I draw with her what was it
like for you August you know cuz they
didn't have any online when you were
doing it all there was no online for me
for me they they would mail you all the
books and I would get like this big box
every couple months you get a new box
I had this Catholic program I think it
was called like Saint Anthony's like
homeschool education
something like that right so they send
you a box every couple of months and I
remember getting those boxes man you
just hear like a knock on the door UPS
guy delivers it and you saw that big box
like you knew like oh [ __ ] like we're
starting up again you know
ya know online or anything like that I
think it's different for me it's gonna
be really hard for your daughter I had a
lot of siblings right I got three
sisters yes and we tired each other out
and I annoyed the [ __ ] out of them and
you know your daughter only has you guys
that like wife is limping no I played
tag with her she forgot she was 50 man
you know I tried to play badminton what
I was limping for two days you know
before they said not go to the park yeah
I would take it to a corner of like a
[ __ ] none of these parks around here
yeah and I played badminton with her
until somebody some [ __ ] [ __ ]
that up and showed up but I play
badminton whether I take it against the
garage I throw curves at her you know
she swings I mean you could just do this
all day all so long I gotta hit the
mitts and throw kicks and workout for 20
minutes you know I don't put that
[ __ ] television on cuz she'll lose
her mind it's not allowed on the house
till 5:00 say that's something that my
parents didn't do they let us watch TV
whatever no I got it yeah okay so I'm
watching TV in the daytime just a bad
app yeah just about but I knew that
there's a I'm not the type we got to
stay on well right what's your job you
gotta get out yeah and I make a living
God yeah justify your existence yeah and
that's how my mother raised me you gotta
get up you gotta get out you know now
till today I know if I don't take a
shower by 9:30 9:00 9:15 I'm gonna go on
to the Depression so it don't matter
what I got something to do I don't have
nothin to do I jump in that [ __ ]
shower what does that mean depression
like you know do you mind
listen bro right now most people's mind
you know people are having nightmares
have you read about I know I guess okay
people having nightmares people having
vivid dreams yeah that means that this
information has gotten into you it's
gotten into your psyche mm-hmm I am not
mad at you for being scared like that
yeah I do
I I understand every emotion you might
have right
as a human being as an American I
understand every emotion maybe you're
not scared of it maybe you're scared of
it
maybe you respect it hmm I respect it I
don't know what's going on and I'm
mother scientist yeah I know they're out
of caskets
you know I know they've been tore my
friend has they said they're gonna lay
people off at the hospital right but
everywhere else people are telling you
these bodies everywhere
you know people today they had some
black guy they showed his dick by
mistake breathing they shocked them you
know and hospitals in the Bronx this
[ __ ] so you don't know I know one person
who's had it I heard uh Michael yo has I
heard that him whatever Tiffany Haddish
had to cough you know I've just heard
little things but I know one person who
died from it but you never know because
if you die from an ingrown toenail now
thinking I saying it's gonna ruin a
right yes oh did you hear that by the
way there's a bunch of doctors that like
came out and said that they were yeah
you've heard you hear so many things
your mind does I know what to believe
anymore so what you I hear so many
different things you know what I'd do it
five I put the TV on and I go on the
back yard at the back that's when the
Sun is the best yeah at five I had that
five on board two pieces and it's been
like that for years at five because we
finished karate at five but kickboxing
fire so four [ __ ] years has been
boring I said you know what [ __ ] this
morning workout in the morning I walk I
come here I park I go for a walk around
the corner I walk the [ __ ] I'll buy
my house and walk those little signs
she's but I like walking by my house is
too many [ __ ] people
yeah [ __ ] ton of people out here around
the office there ain't nobody you can
walk from here to the [ __ ] to the
oviduct and back that's like got a
couple times
ya know ain't nobody on this side of
town because this is where they Park for
the Train right so ain't nobody taking
on the train too right it's parking
spots all over here that they get you
can't even flat nobody [ __ ] tires we
just walk around my house like over and
over and over again with the dog it's
like all you can do
on the weekend we went in we went to
Marina del Rey and I go you know what
we'll go for a ride and if we see that
it's not too crowded we'll go for a walk
you know around those houses at least
it's fresh air by the water and I you
won't believe how many people were out
it's great on the bikes biking hiking
walking in groups no masks cops two cops
that I've Mike Lee there's cops they're
not gonna let us walk around here
without a mask and they're like no cops
no mask just walking around I couldn't
believe it
it's unbelievable people out sailing on
the water so when you homeschool what
time did you crack the book my mom was
really good about that like she started
early in the morning I couldn't tell you
an exact time but I'd say let's say 9:00
let's say 9:00 o'clock in the morning
then what what did you do from knowing
could what was your day like he sat at
the kitchen table with my mom like I
said no computers no online so my mom
was the teacher she was there and she
sat there with me at the table the
entire time and she would go subject by
subject
you know you do each each each day you
had a different little project or
program or something just subject by
subject and then then I would even get
like homework afterwards she saved a
little something for you to work on by
yourself and then after that was over it
was a few hours then you can go I can go
watch TV at stairs probably done by like
close to 4:00 wow that's a long day yeah
but you know I have sisters that are
pretty close in age like my sister at
about me is only two years old me and
she had it too and my mom would have to
switch between us and do it because
we're different grades we couldn't go at
the same time who are learning different
[ __ ] so yeah close too close to like
four I'd be done it then I can go do
whatever I want I remember I used to go
watch Power Rangers that came on like at
4:00 that was my [ __ ] when I was a
little kid you know I could watch that
and then it was just TV dinner and I'd
have to go do the homework which was
just you know the leftover probably
should let me do Bob on my own and then
in the morning she'd look at my homework
that I did and she'd have to like see
what I got correct school from
kindergarten all the way to high school
I never went to a school what was the
reasoning my parents are very what's the
word like overprotective my oldest
oldest sister went to a public school
and she got into some trouble
she got kicked out of a bunch of school
she used to get into fights and stuff
and my dad was already a paranoid person
and they just pulled they pulled her out
and then the rest of us were all
homeschool very sheltered like right now
what everybody's going through with this
quarantine [ __ ] like that was my life I
didn't go outside like we weren't
allowed to go out by ourselves unless we
had like company by one of our parents
or something like that like they were
very protective so like this is what I
grew up on just staying in the house and
if you wanted to go out and like ride a
bike we'd all have to go well this is
what's making this a lot easier that you
guys generations we raised in the house
yeah I was talking to a friend of mine
that he goes if this would have been
1980 we would open yeah because our
generation did not stay on we did not
stay on them there was no reason to be
in the house you got home from school
you did homework and you went out till
10 o'clock that [ __ ] night yeah you
know when you did a thousand things were
football hockey football basketball
right chasing a kid down the block
whatever the [ __ ] it was got a paper
route you know so this generation these
last couple generations it's easier
because their home like I got a stay on
my door to go out like I don't want her
to be have that right so that's why I
told my wife I go war out here they 15 I
think that's good it's listen man it's
not like I didn't go outside like I went
out you know I was I was constantly at
my grandmother's house my dad my
grandfather had a garden and you know
Italians they're always growing their
own vegetables and [ __ ] I did all that
[ __ ] like I grew up in the dirt you know
I mean I had a childhood I don't make it
sound like I didn't and I think that
people don't have a childhood their
immune system today as they're older or
is not as good like you see like all
these like 20 year olds in the hospital
getting the corona virus and it's like
how does that happen you know what I
mean like an older person I get it a
baby I get it how I was like sown in
their 20s getting it it's because like
you said our generation they didn't go
outside these Millennials or whatever
you want to call them they grew up on
video games computers they didn't have a
child or they didn't go out and get
dirty you know you have a joke I swam in
the Hudson you know what I'm saying like
you have a really strong immune system
probably and these other kids they just
they were in the house they grew up in a
bubble you know and this they're gonna
catch it easy it well
there's me - no I can tell when
somebody's not gonna [ __ ] do it
because it's all part of it you got to
get out the hustle yeah you can't do
none of them mouths nothing happens at
the house yeah you know so you don't get
out your life is done why come from
there's nothing going on I got really
mad at a friend of mine the other day I
was calling and checking on a couple
buddies and I and and he goes oh I'm
doing okay except that my sleeping
patterns are off and he was just like
you know I sleep at different hours I
don't know what day it is I don't know
what time it is and I got a little mad
at him because I was just like I know
it's it's common I'm like you're a
comedian bro and I'm like if you
normally before this quarantine [ __ ]
if you normally set the alarm for 8:00
you still have to set it I don't care if
you're quarantined I'm like you stuff to
set the alarm for 8:00 get up shower put
your clothes on like it like you're
going out even if you're staying in or
working from home like you know I'm not
saying like don't wait lay around in
your pajamas like pretend like you got a
job but now you're gonna go work for
yourself that's why I would never want
an office in my house mmm I do certain
things in that office but I get up yeah
you don't have a one on office in your
house not productive you're not gonna be
productive yeah there's too many
distractions you're not gonna be
productive
trust me I'm Tania I've done this for 30
[ __ ] I've seen comics disappeared
it's not productive you cannot be
productive in the house yeah you have to
get out of the house and you have to
make it happen it's not gonna happen for
you you could just send so many emails
mm-hmm you gotta make call you gotta get
out you gotta you know and now the
coffee shops are closed yeah that's what
most people understand I think my
computer I'll sit in the [ __ ] car
really I think a notebook and just take
it in the car with me and go for a ride
you have to get out as a human being I
feel that you know when people told me I
got the pressure off cause you didn't do
dick you don't do dick you don't do dick
yeah you know you're frustrated so it
leads to depression
sorry yeah you gotta move it's it's
savage trim like this is what with my
daughter like I think it started going
into her ear about the curling iron
mm-hmm and she started with that [ __ ]
only one side Wow you gotta go
so I put her on a point system a star
system so she gets 20 stars she gets to
stay up till 10:00
so I she's up to ten stars right now and
that's how I work with her well times
the curve fruit you normally 8:30 okay
but I could walk in that 9:15 and she
still [ __ ] and jumping up and down
and they're just gonna ask would she
stay up you know my wife goes out she's
like what the [ __ ] she doing that she
reads books [ __ ] elephants you know
well Lucy keeps yourself entertained for
being a single child she does a good job
she's got Lego she's got the [ __ ] in
whatever but uh I mean you gotta give
her credit for that I do give her a lot
of credit man I've talked her off a
ledge it's been tough it's been tough
because she's scared so I had to get her
run scared you know she does a podcast
every week right she has to prepare it
she has to watch she started watching
videos about the potica like like I told
her I go listen just could you read
about the [ __ ] elephant I'd wanna
chew start watching the documentaries
like tonight there watch yourself mmm
about Australia at 8 o'clock with the
good-looking heavens worth only oh yeah
there's Chris Hemsworth I was doing some
on that Geo oh so she's watching that so
she'll watch it now I got a common end
and she'll talk about the homework
assignment but then she'll [ __ ] get
off the notebook and just talk to me
which is what I wanted yeah podcast now
she's going well so now she's getting
like she's getting really yesterday's
podcast was a half hour
what are they normal 34 minutes 15 you
know 15 20 to 21 now she's like [ __ ] it
give me 9 pages ha ha so she'd we broke
up elephant part 1 part 2 you know so
now what are you doing this summer did
you also home school in the summer was
it year round of the Julie yeah it was
year round there was there was no like
scheduling for us for our family anyway
with home school like there were some
days where we didn't even do school like
my mom would fall off the wheel a little
bit you know what I mean like we just
like would miss a day and
there was no I I have like a vague
reference of what was summer what was it
you know I mean I guess a lot of kids do
that right you know it's like kind of a
vague reference when you're a kid you
don't remember a lot but uh I don't know
man they summer spring it didn't matter
like it didn't matter it was just always
work to do I just remember what when you
would finish all the programs in the box
you had a little bit of like a vacation
too until the next box came maybe a
month so that was that was like your
summer like you got like a month off
until the next box came depending on how
quick you went through the first box of
[ __ ] you know I've always worked with
her with the summers like this camp like
this year there's no camp at the one
place we're all waiting to hear on the
other place uh-huh and what I've done is
when I was a kid I think one of the best
things that helped me growing up was I
had an aunt in Miami and when I went to
Miami I would spend four weeks of the
shot well that was a kid for the summer
like I would stay at home for two weeks
then go to Miami come back August 15th
and do the last two weeks in New Jersey
until September 4 that's cool yeah I
would go to my mom would go what are you
gonna do it what are you gonna do it
you know play baseball no [ __ ] down
whatever go to Miami go to the ocean my
uncle had a boat we went out fishing you
know [ __ ] like that but you had to do
[ __ ] their mother was a professor in
Cuba so she was by the book so you gotta
basically get up play be in the house at
9:00 and then me she had they had three
kids and when I would come down make it
four so three of us would sit down and
the one daughter would play the piano
and she'd the mine would be whipping her
and whipping us and then one day we'd
have to go to a special teacher's house
a different teacher to get a different
point of view and my mother would send
money down for me to go oh wow and I'll
tell you what all those summers I
excelled the following year when I
stopped doing that in the summer so now
in the summers I work with her you know
even if it's yes like that I just threw
away the paper I had her over here yet
then we were doing division you know she
told me she had a problem with the box
somewhere let's [ __ ] figure it out
yeah
you know what's 4 and then so I've got
her playing with dice like I got
creative I had nice out of Monopoly yeah
I taught how to play blackjack you know
it's the one how to count the cards
right you have to be creative
yeah I don't know I don't know I'm not a
teacher
yeah but I have common sense yeah and I
know how I was taught what I paid
attention to you know one of the biggest
lessons I got growing up was a guy hero
King whoa who left me back he was a
teacher who left me back because I
[ __ ] up but he did some that helped me
at time he made me do oral book report
I do oral book report now right gets a
rat I give her five bucks
uh-huh two stars you know I used to give
her a friend now I give it two stars so
she gets two stars for a little book cuz
I have two questions about the book
what's his character's name where'd he
live so a proper attention gets better
yeah cuz I used to just read and nothing
I would we I could read a book and sit
down go that's why I read now but yeah
you got to work on your comprehension so
I don't read long
yeah I read short okay six seven pages I
put it away to the next day I have a
huge problem with her reading where
that's what I'll do I'll read the same
page over and over again because yeah
we're a long line like my brain just
goes one yes that's it no it makes me
think of something else I could tell you
but the first 10 pages if I'm gonna
stick with it I know Jimmy I could tell
you within the first 10 page if I make
it past 10 pages don't worry yeah
they're worried yeah now I was telling a
Dean dal-rae about a book I read he told
me someone I'm like holy [ __ ] you're
right
I remember reading that but I forgot
about it so it's like my comprehension
still swept you know right and I was but
Dinah asked you for weeks like what's
the deal with this whole but the whole
school I've been dying ass I just didn't
have the balls to [ __ ] points I said
let's do a podcast on it because I know
there's probably a ton of people
homeschool their kids right now the
whole country and they don't know what
the [ __ ] to do yeah you know but they
got the teacher on the Skype right or
the zoom whatever zoom and something
else I mean at least they have that like
when I was a kid there wasn't that like
your mom was the teacher and then I got
to be tough because I would listen to my
mom at all yeah like my mom taught me
time for Revere what screaming [ __ ]
whatever right [ __ ] you you know about
Paul Revere like I would listen to my
mom
uh-huh and that's why I was thinking I
thought somebody came in for you guys
know like I always thinking of trying to
hire somebody come in after this you
know yeah I hated school man I hated it
and and you know I'm sure it was tough
for my mom but a lot of times she would
just feel like this is your chapter
you're reading today read that and then
she'd go over with my sister and do the
same thing and she come back and forth
between us I get the email right here so
I check the email all week okay I
[ __ ] check it out so this isn't gonna
give good evening I hope this email
attached this to [ __ ] time whatever so
what they're basically doing this ain't
gonna come up now no no it did come up
all right so you know zoom rules and
stay focused respectful while on zoom
have all the daily material do not lean
zoom with our permission don't change
the names on the screen no fooling use
the virtual ban hand raise sit up
straight and make sure we can see your
face Monday lessen point eight nine zoom
please have your math lesson ready and
then video she has to know this video so
then Gigi or prodigy 20 minutes that's
like a program and then then they do
extreme math that's daily that's a
different program and then she has 11
o'clock she has phonics skills and
that's Monday zoom meeting have your
grandma spelling words vocabulary Raz
kids or epic for 20 minutes and journal
three to five sentences and then to
tomorrow thank God tomorrow we got Matt
we got language arts and we got art and
you know what she's only got like three
math classes left early so I'm losing my
[ __ ] mind right now that's crazy you
went from like you know big the biggest
part of her school was mainly you
dropping her off and now it went to like
completely your responsibility to make
she sits there she has everything ready
we have a back room which we're gonna do
the podcaster but again I didn't want an
office at that yeah I didn't wanna cuz
that I won't do it that means I'm gonna
walk back there with slippers are mm-hmm
I don't wanna do that
you don't want guests coming in your
house yes no I didn't want people
walking through the backyard but that
was the thing I know that if I would
have done the podcast in my house I
would have been out there with sandals
on and [ __ ] on a flip-flop yeah I'll do
that I don't want to do it I want to be
on point so this when driving over here
at least let you [ __ ] know right you
know yeah so they sit in the back
together
my wife had a blackboard we put a
[ __ ] fake desk back there we put
chairs we got a [ __ ] we call that
[ __ ] for hair is it a seed nothing no
your fan a fog I don't [ __ ] know
event le invites and it keeps it cool
back there and they sit back there and
it's nice then I go back there by 11:00
and I said well there and I watch and
I'll write in my journal sometimes
sometimes I just leave I don't leave
them two alone I can't work out when in
the backyard because I don't want to
distract her so I can't hit the bag I
can't really do nothing so from 10:00 to
12:00 I usually just leave ten to twelve
thirty and you see we just leave go for
a walk maybe run some errands if I have
to you know if I don't for me to do
something I have to go early in the
morning because I don't want to walk
around in somebody else's junk
yeah so I avoid Rob's I avoid all that
should I just go to little bodegas and I
order food it you know great but I make
her do things throughout the day also I
stay on her you know like she tomorrow
she has to hit the pads and she gets
three points so exercise is important
with the other thing because I wanted to
stay fresh and like I said if I don't
wear her out I'm gonna pay for it later
you have to wear her mm-hmm if not she
has nervous breakdown and [ __ ] she says
crying so I can't do it so I work you
know yeah she goes right I get her on at
8:15 bike and then we go back at 12:30 I
have a scooter then hold by the one
Church to have a
ask more written by yourself so I'd make
a play basketball me her and her mother
we do drills new [ __ ] there's nobody
else over that you see you three every
once awhile three white dummies with no
mass I show up and even my daughter goes
let's go really yeah what she don't
trust it no she don't want to see people
with no master man she's like let's get
the [ __ ] out of here let's go this is
tough on everybody it's tough on the
kids and stuff on the difference this is
tough you know hey listen man it's so
funny how I was really scared of that
Comedy Store podcast like I went in
there really apprehensive why I didn't
want to fail okay I know people going
through a hard time and I know people
were expecting to see something so I
pretty much lost my [ __ ] mind and
went off like a [ __ ] animal that I am
you know um it's just so funny then I
didn't really give a [ __ ] because I knew
what I was feeling I didn't want to feel
that normal so if I could take people
away from there for one [ __ ] hour what
they're feeling whether they're broke
you know you know many people are dying
and you can go say goodbye to them yeah
many people lose relatives you know so I
wanted to go on people were expecting
something big and I want to go off big I
showed them my ball about me undies I
shaved my balls I mean I went off I said
things that were inappropriate but I
didn't give a [ __ ] because I just wanted
to take people's mind off this [ __ ] for
one hour I love what I know this it's
been so weird when something comes on
this time something comes on and you
still get like the Michael Jordan thing
cable that's great cuz you're focused
you forget about what's going on you
forget about your job you forget about
everything you just worry you know
you're in the moment yeah it's when you
scatter that it's bad so when you watch
something you've already seen your minds
guys like I can't put the Sopranos on I
can't put tacos on it's like walking
alongside you sit there like a dummy
yeah and then nothing happens so I gotta
watch it that I haven't watched before
they keep you like keep me fresh and
keep my mind I want to get entertained
yeah so if it's something like trains
planes and all
Bill's I watched you for 30 minutes I'll
show you two other stuff and yeah that's
the problem happy so I'm looking forward
to it I still haven't broken down and
watch Joe exotic jogger the Trojan tiger
king I haven't seen it either I just saw
too many people watched it so same here
no offense to anybody out there but I
don't give a [ __ ] if they get offended
if you watch that go [ __ ] you so listen
guys will eat ranch and shoot yourself
world's doing like backflips over it but
like listen I understand you all say
it's great what about you if you know me
make things that I want to watch and do
who does meth and he trains Tigers like
I know where even remotely interested in
the subject but even put it off my wife
oh yeah I don't want to put it up I just
love so much about it was too much with
too much yeah we're still relatively new
into the only been about a month and a
half two months at what point do you
think people just start normalizing it's
already started
it has what dude I joined I want I want
every way every day it's coming back is
the traffic people are going out it's
coming back little by little and you're
gonna and people this not even the worst
part of it I don't think I think there
were we got it it's gonna get worse I
think we're gonna get it's called the W
effect that's what happened with the
Spanish flu so like it's called W cuz it
goes like that like that like that like
that so we're gonna go back to normal
and then everyone's gonna be like yeah
we're gonna go back to the bars and
we're gonna drink it and you're gonna
get it even it's gonna take out even
more people the second time yeah I'm not
going on you got tickets for uncle Joey
past September [ __ ] and draw them away
September 4th and 5th I don't know
what's gonna happen to Philadelphia
yeah I don't know what's gonna happen to
Buffalo but I can't put my family at
risk
yeah I can't be on a plane five and a
half hours I just don't know I have no
desire I think I would pass out as soon
as I put my foot on a plane you think I
would pass out from anxiety Wow I would
have a full-blown panic attack I think I
would have a full ball
panic attack once the wheels went up
when we took off and I'm laughs I just
if you make a plane come down you gotta
pay for that plane if you if they have
to land because of you oh yeah what have
you had like a heart attack did I send
you the bill oh yeah you're gonna build
eventually Wow you know or if you died
on the point you know nobody knows
anything
Wow we have a crystal ball dick but
that's why there's so much fear because
we don't know what we don't know it's
very normal
yeah I had a weird dream last night I
woke me up at 5 to 4 I have dreams all
night the last couple dolls I've been
good though I've got really just I just
keep seeing it online
are you having cold the dreams I'm like
what the [ __ ] I haven't seen that that's
interesting I have because fear has to
trigger something you yeah I got on the
scariest and game like six but really
I'm not in shock you know why cortisol
because well I'm in fear I'm wrong some
cortisol you know I've been sticking to
my points I've been sticking to my hand
Menino much I'm not that hungry
mmm are you scared yes and I'd you know
it was 4:20 Monday yeah I maybe did four
or five on that
I didn't even need another I haven't
even edibles all week I just tried to
give it a break just cuz that's all I
did from what second time right I went
heavy heavy I wasn't happy till about
March 25th then I was like holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I'm just barely hitting
that because we were still in Lent
until recently I went into this
quarantine thing into Lent and I gave up
beer bread I gave up all this [ __ ] for
Lent so I didn't have anything until
like Easter I finally started a drink
now I've been having like beer every
night it's probably why I'm having
dreams because I have like a beer before
I go to bed I'm just barely starting my
little my little binge
what do you think was like the most the
biggest advantage of being homeschooled
over other kids did you have friends
that went regular pot yeah when you were
growing up I didn't
anybody else's homeschooled I all my
friends are public school or private
school I had friends that went to Notre
Dame over here and then some my other
friends with the Grant High School and I
guess that I think that people thought
that I was weird like it's very unusual
at the time and but I mean I had friends
it when I got a little older when I was
a teenager because like I said it when
we were really young I was on the really
a lot of go out alone but I became a
teenager and when I was a teenager I
started to do this school by myself and
then Internet started to come out and by
the time like late high school there was
online opened although it's [ __ ] hot
Jesus Christ oh yeah who knew all that
hooded sweatshirt that's why I was like
[ __ ] it's gonna be hot my podcast mate I
left it was so windy out yeah no it's
earthquake weather uh-huh it's [ __ ]
windy it's [ __ ] sunny it's you know
going into ninety five tomorrow I'm
gonna I think that there's definitely I
guess some advantages I think there's
more disadvantages like I wouldn't if I
had the choice I wouldn't want my kid to
be almost go why I think you miss out on
all social skills you miss out on a lot
of things like a lot of friends I own I
could probably count on maybe one hand
two hands maybe two hands how many
friends I had and you know when you go
to a school you got a lot of friends you
know a lot of people you develop social
skills you go to parties you you go to
dances I didn't have no dance no no
homecoming there was no prom you know
like I feel like that's a lot of like I
don't know special things that kids
always remember high school reunions I
don't I don't have that and I feel like
there's a lot to be miss out on but I
guess there's advantages of it too
because I'm actually proud of the way I
was raised I think that I I didn't not
to be a dick but I don't think I'm as
dumb as a lot of kids no I don't mean
educationally I mean almost kind of like
a street smarts type of thing you know
like I'm not I don't fall for [ __ ] easy
you know I think that part partly had to
do with the way my father
mother raised me and there's some
advantages you probably you know get
into drugs a lot later in life I mean I
got into it anyway well I mean but just
later oh and I was I was not home school
but do you think there's a difference
between maybe joey's DARS age and then
like I feel bad for the people I feel
bad for like the juniors and seniors in
high school right now well you kinda
have to get the SATs ready yeah play
college when you're missing first grade
hopefully won't make that much of an
that I don't know how long this is gonna
last
yeah if if it lasts September I'm
listening to a different school mmm she
can't be at all all day you're gonna
kill it it's gonna come back to bite us
in the ass all this generation now a lot
of people have seen this type of stuff
yeah Lorna's this generation is
everybody everybody's in shell shock you
know I don't I feel bad for a lot of
people I know people are hurt and
financially I know people are hurt in so
many ways but you know what man I'm
hurting but I make myself laugh every
day
III forced myself to do things I don't
want to do for the sake of mental health
I knew that this is gonna affect a lot
of mental health
yesin if I didn't take care of it I'm
scared I tell people all the time I do a
lot of acid as a kid so I feel like I'm
gonna snap any day anyway I'm just
waiting for me to [ __ ] my pants or throw
it at somebody with the cops or
something man they just [ __ ] put me
in a mental ward
you know like I don't know but I've
always been scared of that I've always
dealt with fear I've always had the
anxiety so altogether like I'm scared of
these type of period can I ask you a
question though like we like from -
since 2001 we pretty much had a war
going on constant consistent Lee and
like that how like why do you think this
is scary to some people then because
they're not sure over here there's a 3d
model wherein wrong but it was in Iraq
yeah
bomb went off here we don't even know
about that well yeah I don't even we
never really listen it takes somebody
not too many people are socially
conscious you know I know there's a war
going on but I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
I'm not in it yeah I know our country's
in it but it's not like I'm following it
I don't know the rules of it or whatever
if if it came closer to home we know
about it but for years we've known that
there's wars going on at all times
around the world yeah just because
you're living here and the Sun's up
somebody's having a bad time so you know
you have to assume it if you know
anything about life so I think this is a
war right now I mean my personal opinion
I think this is a bio weapon I think
this is a weapon I don't think it was an
accident
personally that's what I think I mean
they found three different things in it
it's not just
kovin 19 Colvin is like it's been around
for a while it's cut with kovat it's cut
with HIV and one other thing yeah that's
somebody that somebody created that and
the reason that I heard it doesn't have
the effect of HIV not to same symptoms
but it's cut with HIV so that it spreads
faster it's easy to catch
so like someone planned this it's like
it's pretty I mean someone when we know
who did it but I don't [ __ ] it nobody
knows nothing yeah that's it yeah we
don't know we don't know nobody knows
nothing man it's uh it's a hard time but
[ __ ] you know you have to push
yourself you have to make yourself laugh
you have to walk you have to keep
yourself fresh because if not I mean
it's been this like I said it's April
23rd and I've been home since March 7th
pretty much I haven't done comedy since
March 2nd so I'm feeling it I've gone
through changes since this this is this
is you know and I and it's all
understandable you know we just I just
want everybody to listen there's
whatever going on I don't know what it
is whether it's a bio weapon the whole
flu I don't know what it I do know one
thing I do know that you Joe listener
has to take care of itself
your family you know be home not go some
lady don't belong you know if you see a
line outside of a place you don't really
want to eat there you don't really want
to eat there this is not the time to
wait on line for anything but the most
important thing about this even so
you're avoiding this kovat yeah and I
understand that and I appreciate that
but at the same time you also have to
avoid you go crazy
yeah and those walls getting slowly on
you you know drinking is up 60% uh-huh I
spoke to my coke dealer buddy
my Cody he says he just called to check
in no he wanted uh he saw the video from
manscape oh yeah so he wanted the code
he goes I forgot the code I want to look
good oh my god there's [ __ ]
snorting 24 hours yeah I thought you
serious he goes bro there's people I
dropped it off at 6:00 in the morning
for they just lock the door me get in
five when I drop you off at six the
morning there's all pipe yeah [ __ ] going
on we have a mutual friend that just
texted me a photo with the little hole
in the straw
oh you're the mask and he was doing a
line with the mask on and it goes stay
safe no people are drinking he was
smoking people people are doing anything
that will make them feel better you know
and with me I'm just happy to be home
I'm happy to be raising my daughter I'm
happy I honestly thought the second week
that something bad was going to happen
in my house tensions were just little
too high my wife was tense I was tense
mercy was starting to get tense and one
night I had a little I thought about my
past I just went in two places I should
have been and I came clean with my wife
about what was happening with me you
know if she's like wait I didn't your
office for
I told I feel like [ __ ] this is what I
did as a kid you know this is what
happens playing with me and she's like
alcohol and then it since that night
we've been best friends there's no drama
in my house there's no stress it's just
we've accepted it like this is what we
do I was really scared in the beginning
I thought you know they're talking about
domestic violence is gonna go up and
people gonna kill their wives I don't
know I'm [ __ ] scared as it is I mean
I'm sure everybody handles things
differently but I told my wife you love
it without drinking yeah aren't you
lucky without a couple of drinks cuz
right now somebody was shot so that's
you know this is if you drink every
night with your significant other and
you're both going broke right now yes
any idea and now people start pointing
fingers at each other you should've kept
your job a Lubriderm such a [ __ ] I told
you not to put that part-time job so I
could totally said evidence you see that
I could see that that this is why you
have to stay on top of your mental game
right now yes your mental game I brought
I look at my journal it's garbage I
write a great journal I write what
happened yesterday how I feel what I
expect from today what happened to what
he is a gold today you got to read my
journals them and take the same sentence
over and over again I read it like three
hours later I'm like I'm dog [ __ ] huh I
am dog [ __ ] so I get it I get it every
angle the most important thing right now
is yeah taking care of your immune
system
eating zinc vitamin C drinking water
vitamin D kills this [ __ ] can't last him
the Sun yeah so vitamin D kills this
[ __ ] so get on that [ __ ] Sun every
day yeah and the other thing you got to
work on number two is your fitness then
we go [ __ ] stale your lungs don't
breathe you know
that's number two did you see the email
I put in dr. melesa
know that deep breathing helps you for
the knees type of situation so as gay as
this sounds everybody I know people
gonna be mad at me for saying this I end
my workout every day like if I work on
like four days a week you know sometimes
I walk 20 minutes and then I'd work out
15 20 minutes at
we cantle bells or whatever but my last
10 minutes of work and I have honestly
there's yoga yeah dog leg stretches cat
pose baby pose and then I actually take
my shoes off in the back I sit in the
Sun I do a yoga pillow I do a couple
downward dogs and I [ __ ] meditating I
put the two fingers like this hell yeah
close my eyes the Sun and I work on my
breathing and make sure that my stomach
goes all the way back just like doctor
police had told me yeah
and dunk the first two minutes is a
nightmare you're breathing and you're
thinking about negative [ __ ] and comedy
gigs and who hates you and who's mad at
you and it's all [ __ ] and after you
start breathing like three or four
minutes it's just silence the only thing
I hear is a helicopter or a plane coming
over and I'll sit there in the Sun and
stop breathing no sit down that position
I'll hold it for six or seven minutes it
feels good right
I get up I stretch out again I put my
palms out I get the energy from the Sun
yeah I thank the Sun for being out there
I take my t-shirt off I think my sweats
off right in the kitchen I throw it in
the washing machine I take a [ __ ] job
that's it but most of my workout now is
basically stretching working on my
breathing and then meditate as gay as it
sounds I don't think it's gay at all has
anybody because I know that it lowers
your blood pressure I know it clears
your mind I know that you know and I do
the whole thing I closed my eyes I focus
up I go for the third eye you know I
worked on my breathing and then that's
eight or nine minutes and snap out of it
you know am I gonna do what namaste will
you lay up Hey shavasana it's good for
you man what an anxiety can kill you too
bug I know for a fact that every time I
in another boy I had [ __ ] Kovac one
[ __ ] audible within an hour I got
cold in this yeah come online looking
for symptoms and [ __ ] had a stop yeah
because in my mind I had cold it
you get a headache now oh my god you got
Kovac yeah and [ __ ] hurt you got
coping you know I can take care of
yourself you don't even want to get a
cold because they're gonna look at you
like you got kovat or something you
don't I mean like Kiki you gonna take
care of yourself you know as gay as it
sounds I wear this mask I got ten of
them
I got like on you man yeah I got like a
hundred regular ones and then I got like
these b-52s well I had 95 I got like 20
of these [ __ ] I switch Ahmad I
throw them away yeah you know if I walk
into anywhere whatever I have on comes
off when I go right into the [ __ ]
thing I'm trying really hard but I
didn't take no chances I knew that the
physical and the mental were just as
important as the immediate part of it
yeah I knew it I [ __ ] know it the
whole time I knew for me for me with my
[ __ ] skeletons I knew that they would
[ __ ] come on for me if I didn't
[ __ ] haunt them first so I had to tap
on that door go I'm here [ __ ] what's
the problem what do you so what I did
this ooh hit in the 6th grade so what I
had this in the 8th grade so what so I
was getting all judgmental about myself
and beat myself up dog until last night
until that Comedy Store podcast I was
quitting on me no I swear to God
last night revitalized me like a
[ __ ] I needed that so badly last
night I've been able to go off like I
said every time a [ __ ] animal bro I
got a different pace I can't breathe
this [ __ ] oh my god and when I workout
too but I walk there at 5 the first five
minutes I'm gonna die the sun's hitting
me it's hot I feel a little pricklies
and [ __ ] that first ball of sweat comes
to a burns my eyeballs because God knows
what's coming out of my body
you know you've been home so God knows
what's coming out of my [ __ ] body so
I just try to sweat it out as much as I
can every [ __ ] day yeah that's all
you could do I prepared for this I had
to I had to mentally prepare myself for
this I had to write my own obituary
yeah about two weeks ago what's the fear
about what am I scared about I wrote my
obituary I wrote a [ __ ] mass card you
know beloved son the whole [ __ ] deal
I don't want to know yeah but people
don't usually write their own but you do
this I think MacArthur will somebody
please tweet me if they read this
somebody and somebody was blowing a war
and made their troops write their
obituary Wow
to take the fear away and I remember
reading this years ago when I was a kid
reading about this and then it was
brought up in a movie and I was like
that's right
I read that years ago you write your
obituary that's super interesting [ __ ]
it that's it no I'm not scared no more
cuz you got all that right now but a mom
done that worried about your loved ones
yeah what people gonna think about you
you got it out I write a journal for my
daughter so she knows all the story so
nobody could tell her a [ __ ] lie yeah
she knows all the stories I got pictures
that she'll get special pictures and
then nobody's seen before I have
pictures of my other daughter so she
knows she has a sister I write a journal
for her and I read my journal
that's great and that I just knew for me
the mental health aspect I'm petrified
petrified that I'm gonna [ __ ] pull
him or enlarge get a gun and go to
Ventura Boulevard and start shooting up
in the [ __ ] air it's in my blood well
I think it's interesting you said that
because I even said last night when I
called you is you sounded relaxed after
the the part oh my god so what are you
you got that out there has to be
something that normal people who might
not be stand-ups can do that something
like they normally did that would like
help them feel more normal or something
like you did he sounded like you like
you had sex or something after he
sounded very relaxed last night last
night was the [ __ ] big changing for
me cuz I didn't want to do it I thought
I was gonna fall apart there I just
didn't want to do it and then I was like
how can I not like I wanted to really
help the waitstaff you know it's funny
when I went back to New York in May I
had a long talk with myself and I was
looking at these friends of mine I grew
up with dad this is way before ID
economy in any movies you know anybody
could be my friend now but to be my
friend then took a lot I was a kid I was
a heavy-duty friend you were gonna get a
call every week about me it took it took
a strong friend to be my friend so when
I went back in May and I sat across and
my friends I would look at them while
they were eating and we'd be talking
like oh this [ __ ] robbed three
houses with me and this [ __ ] you
know I talked to a friend of mine
yesterday and I go do you know that
during this [ __ ] whole thing I
realized why you made gotta fight me and
have been friends since we were kids we
didn't talk for like 20 years and he
asked me once he goes why did we stop
talking and I go I don't know because he
was a state wrestler and he was going to
the States we wish we were juniors in
high school well he was a sophomore and
I was in junior then we used to rob this
gas station every other month right
every other month we'd robbed this gas
station you beat up Freddie
and then we finally beat Freddie and
then we just kept robbing it we would
hit it once a month and one night we
were getting some coke like I had plans
to get some coke so it was like just no
like when you pick me up we're gonna go
in Putnam field first like that's the
way it was and what are we doing tonight
before we do anything we gotta go put a
gun to Putnam feel I robbed a guy he's
gonna have 400 of them because they drop
every time they had 400 so the most
you're gonna get is 380 and the cops
ain't gonna come to tunnel you have no
it was right next to this place called
snappy nappy I don't please keep your
tummy happy come to snappy nappy if a
rat meat I mean I don't know how many
rats I ate in that place that show my
gosh that chili one time I feel like a
rat's tail with it oh you have no idea
snapping that B's till this day Lee
knows likely psyche honey now it's
lizard me cuz I hate it I've seen it
before you understand me I hate it when
I was the eighth grade we used to ride
our bikes down there I swear to God I
saw a [ __ ] a little mouse tail oh one
time and I had
come on because who gives a [ __ ] it's
the same yeah we Chinese food we know
they're cooking cats we still go down
there you know you're eating it you're
like this tastes like dog it just tastes
like copper spray you this man this
tastes like tears some little boys tears
it comes with a wanted poster poster
with a kid oh this dog yeah missing dog
poster you know we know when you eat at
those places that with your eating you
just make-believe like yeah but then one
day I stopped like I like veal
scaloppini
I hate lamb I hate goat I hate all that
really but veal scaloppini done right
when they cut it with the razor or the
spins oh my god there's tremendous how
to stop eating it yeah thinking of Bambi
yeah goats with the [ __ ] yeah you
know you stop that [ __ ] yeah dude so
what happened was I guess bTW the Rob
Putnam with mean he's like Dahmer I got
this big we can't keep robbing it
somebody you're either gonna Rob it but
you're not doing coke to her he goes I
won't do coke I said stop it
so I just got a friend like yo you're
robbing gas station and the kids like
there's gonna work out and I drew a
diagram for him his name is Louie cast
Leto on Facebook if you don't believe
him hit him up on Facebook go do you
still have the diagram he still has to
die he saved it and he brought it to my
show and [ __ ] off what a lot of the
hilarious what two years ago not this
last time when I was in Miami the time
before that when I was in West Palm
Beach of what Lydell he goes blonde
number this he goes this was the getaway
route that you told me what he was right
here because I never robbed anything and
you took me down there we robbed his guy
because I was never so scared in my life
is like you had done it every day I
would just go in there but I would take
DD the guy didn't know who I was
we had a guy that was on the inside and
then after we burned him we would rob
him and then we were supposed to be were
split the money with him and me and did
he bought an Eightball we snorted the
whole thing we never came back
so he got fired so now we had a robbery
without no we were taking a chance every
time so that's the reason so yeah night
like the other night I'm like why didn't
mean Dini stop talking and I wanted to
deep and I'm like that's right Loic
Ashley no brought that letter to the
[ __ ] Improv about me [ __ ] me give
them the diagram of how we're gonna run
upon the fuel cuz we were gonna we're
not gonna run to tell me we're gonna run
the long way Westside Avenue we just sit
across the street you don't know how
many times people robbed that gas
everybody robbed that guy so you needed
20 bucks you robbed that gas station
like that's what it became Wow
so they knew they were getting robbed
and then they started putting two people
and three people from that we could rob
but that's true like I thought out for
20 years I'm like why didn't me and
beanie stop talking it was because of
that gas thing I got pissed off when you
leave when I robbed it we've robbed this
place every Tuesday night what do you
mean cocoa everyone like it was dessert
like you're not doing coke no Robbie
don't go clean yeah well you don't have
money how can I cut you in on the coke
so am I gonna cut you another coke he
thought he was just gonna [ __ ]
quarterback and I'm Czech water bag and
I was gonna give him coke [ __ ] you [ __ ]
away this [ __ ] game yeah no [ __ ]
giveaway program so it's just it's just
crazy where your mind goes on these
times [ __ ] girl that fell off a bike
when I was a kid I got the blame for it
you know like like I was Friday that the
[ __ ] girl me and the girl were like a
love and we broke up we were friends and
also what then she takes my bike I had
the blame for that you know so I felt
bad about that yeah you know I just was
feeling bad about my life and that's
what happens when my wife goes to bed
man 15 there and the doors start closing
in on me
so I drink like [ __ ] I got these
things keep them all these [ __ ]
put you out this is like a THC
oh yeah how many milligrams just so the
people know how do you date how many
take two or three took more bad two
milligrams of THC in three milligrams of
CBN I'll take three of those and a cup
of that teeth this company Kiko mold
does a tea and it's the same thing the
tea is 2 milligrams the tea is less the
tea is the same so I'll do like three of
these and that tea because everything in
this is for you to sleep it's like a
couple of weeks ago you fell asleep on
Twitch he was snoring and [ __ ] because
there's a thing you could drink it's
like a quick that's mix of melatonin
like a B melatonin heavy [ __ ] ginger
root
everything that puts you to sleep plus
100 milligrams of THC how long does it
take to kick in 2 minutes take it here
then drive a couple these now just come
on ready yeah
you're gonna fall asleep at the wheel I
won't fall asleep I go home
you fell asleep on Twitch your people
watch dog fell asleep snoring the whole
[ __ ] thing you watched it
people will hit me that night what the
[ __ ] I don't know what I was saying I
didn't know what they were saying to me
and the next morning they're like look
at your boy and it opens up to him like
oh that's like when all sudden the
[ __ ] every time every time he was
snoring the camera was moving back you
can see the camera moving back off and
the camera broke anyway I move this
little thing a little [ __ ] [ __ ] put
his arms up that look like a little bit
mumbles some words a little box
wait that's hilarious and then he
stopped looking at the screen and people
like wake up [ __ ] with Tom for
Joey yes and you can see in this face
how many hours is that go on for hours
at all I was like I can't do like I fall
asleep here okay like I fall asleep in
this chair and I have comfortable chairs
in my living room
yes [ __ ] that's why I didn't
bring no edibles with me cuz I call them
the more like where's the video you know
I believe I haven't once I fell asleep
in the morning we mean you fell asleep I
fell asleep with the garb one night I'm
like um he's gonna be Chapter one of
these homeless people's gonna see this
door opening coming here mr. cheese oh
yeah don't jump that [ __ ] fence these
people crazy this name oh yeah
especially now man crime is at an
all-time high
I heard they're breaking into a lot of
cars yeah that's like I told you mine
right I didn't tell you know do it I
went out and they took the hood oh
that's right the grille off my car this
is the hood they took the stole the hood
the grill fender liners from like the
inside and a couple other like they took
the bolts for the hill now you have a
Prius
I sold the Prius okay and then they did
this on a my Jeep I got a Jeep Cherokee
no [ __ ]
yeah they and they and they apparently
the Jeep Cherokee grills I guess ever of
aftermarket values that's why they steal
them and apparently the bolts that hold
down the hood are like $12 a piece and
there's like 20-something bolts so they
steal the bolts and everything cuz
they're expensive so when you woke up
that morning he was like a [ __ ] April
Fool's joke I went out to my car like
and I was just sitting there and the
gardener was out there like mowing by my
car and we like made eye contact and I'm
like good morning and then he's like
looking at me weird and then I looked
over at my hood and I'm like oh I see
what you're looking at me weird about
just [ __ ] everything gone dude I just
barely got it back it was in the shop
for three weeks
Oh
everything's like working a lot slower
now because nobody's really open the
factory they give you rent the corn all
that sure everything my insurance paid
for everything
that's crazy there's nothing like
[ __ ] surprising the [ __ ] out of
somebody like it's the worst I just have
a buddy who was crazy I loved him with
all my heart
rest in peace his name was Darren Ranco
and he was a garbage man for a while
uh-huh so we found out what it was
all right so me my buddies those metal
garbage cans yeah put briquette will put
blocks in there and ate its brick yeah I
put like a garbage bag over it and we'd
sit with binoculars and watch you jump
off the chocolate five of the garbage
can Tina this before the machine yeah
yeah so this is with two idiots they
hang on the back of the back uh-huh and
then they look in front of your house
and the best is like in Jersey they come
out you have a couch and they're like we
won't take out you give 20 bucks they're
gonna [ __ ] couch in there they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah and it matches it but
so this guy this guy was a bodybuilder
so we get all cuffed up and we go let's
go it's 4:30
what time is Ray go take that garbage
we're like 5:30 6:00 so we would go to a
garbage can fill it up with bricks and
then take the garbage can across the
street because we didn't know what side
he was gonna be huh okay no it's so he
jump off the thing started [ __ ] and then
get the one garbage can and gonna pick
it up and say and he yell [ __ ] cuz he
knew was that first you didn't know we
would do this to him like every week
just set up garbage cans just put
weights in it
blocks [ __ ] bottles and he would come
on in you see him pull and he's like
[ __ ] and then we would ask me questions
get the break is back oh my god we would
ask him questions how is work some
[ __ ] on 76th Street for [ __ ]
heavy [ __ ] though we didn't know we
would sit there why
Jim like all cops up then he figured out
it was up what would you put in there
like wait we draw like let's say we had
to drive to [ __ ] please like on the
way there okay stop by that construction
site let's steal some [ __ ] blocks and
summated you brick and we go by your
house and put barbells in there like a
45 pound weight and he common child like
he'd be walking on his feet like
whistling Dixie yeah I hate gonna pick
up that garbage can they would be what
like 200 [ __ ] pound and he'll get
this you'd have to drag it the brick
purpose we did this for about six months
before he caught on he would come out he
would be pissed somebody's [ __ ] with
me I'm gonna find them in the man
there's nothing you're giving people
ideas right now this nothing
oh my god don't move kids some states
still do it like that
the other night I was watching oh my god
the worst movie of all time the Ice Man
movie oh yeah with Michael Shannon yeah
it's got off I've never seen it it's
god-awful
hey you know what I know that whole
story but the guy that plays the ice
cream man in there that's what we used
to he used to live on the street called
Charles Court uh-huh I mean it was the
darkest side of the street there was a
street light so the darkest sides of the
street Charles Court was a circle it's
like what he called us call this a cult
yeah yeah yeah there's Long Island in
the middle like a roundabout right but
very small it was just a regular block
with little island in the middle had two
houses so when he will go up the corner
and you will go this way there would be
lights but once you got to over here it
was very dark
huh and then there was a streetlight
over here and once she went down about
20 more yards it was pitch dark
so what we would do is we wait till the
fall and we get 90 blocks and we built
like a brick wall in the middle of
street and put leaves on look like it
was a bundle of leaves so you're there
with your Mustang here like oh [ __ ] look
these leaves so we would do it we would
do two roadblocks we would get you in
front of prong gaze house and then once
you hit the wall and you wet it out
again we had we got another wall down
here so you would actually hit two walls
you'd get out of cars die yelling you
[ __ ]
you dirty sons of [ __ ] and we'd be
[ __ ] that's exactly what we do every
time as a teenager we'd [ __ ] polish
planks oh no this was this is when I was
in the 8th grade coffee at night
this was 8th grade seventh grade at
night and then there was a police phone
and we ripped that out every night in
the car to come how old you in 8th Grade
12 okay
14 the crew I hung out with there that's
what we did pranks that's what we did
there was a lady who had a fish tank
like a bowl in front of a house with
fish we put lighter fluid in there light
on fire with the fish and she come out
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Chinese boy we lit on fire for
like a month and a happened cuz you just
took we killed like a thousand we killed
more fish than cancer like the straws we
would put dogs used to have those big
goldfish in there then lock the door
yeah we just put lighter fluid up on top
oh my god hey what do you then do I was
made yeah I was a dumb kid that's who we
do and then we'd run down the block and
there was like a [ __ ] thing and then
there was a guy that did ceramics and he
would sit at this house why do we throw
rocks at the woods about we throw
exactly I mean this was constant yeah
that street down there you know if you
didn't tip like if you like it we
shoveled your driveway and you didn't
tip you were done on Halloween you know
me garbage cans with an on fire
yesterday because my daughter we had to
get a bicycle not for me but I'm gonna
ride it my wife got like a use
whatever the [ __ ] you call it like okay
no the other ones the beachcombers Oh
like a cruiser yeah my wife said some
lady had it for 35 bucks off of the
truck you know it's funny I bought a
used bike yesterday you boy no I
we were tuning it up today uh-huh and
they [ __ ] put check you know stuff on
the chain I kind the thing as I
tightened the pedals and she goes what
are you tightening and I go the [ __ ]
handlebars mmm and she goes why I'm
trying I told this drag on the Taser one
time I don't know what I did I bumped
into a hundred bucks and the hottest
bike when I was a kid was the Apollo
racer and then handlebars and the
[ __ ] thing in the back what he called
[ __ ] bar I don't know you guys are too
young so he stood up on it yeah it was
three [ __ ] speeds it was see if you
see Apollo racer but the picture of
D'Agostino this is the baddest bike in
the world and they gave one away every
Sunday I wonder Abba that was a kid
there was a show called wonder Rama on
Channel five and everybody from eight to
eleven and on Sundays they would [ __ ]
they would play wonder arm and you could
register the what a bicycle that was the
[ __ ] Apollo click onto one of them
you see that she knows that was yeah
collar race you see those handlebar yeah
so I bought one of those at Sears
Roebuck and I actually the guy goes you
wanted to build it for you no no no no
just give me 10% off and give me the
damn key Oh God looks at me like what
the [ __ ] you talking about you're a kid
nobody has a tempest yeah I'll get 10%
off and I'll buy the demonstrator cuz I
don't have time for him to build it she
goes okay I'll give you whatever you
want I gave him the money cash and I got
on the bicycle now I lived on a hill
every Hill was I had to go down Sears
Hill and then now the Chinese Hill which
is [ __ ] like this we saw ste with the
Chinese store [ __ ] steep and then my
block is a [ __ ] hill so I went all
the way home on hills nothing at all the
hard part is going back uphill yeah I
didn't go to everyone but you know those
hills that they were keeping me alive
today walking those hills as a kid
there's a there's a there's a Facebook
Paige called them the hills of North
Bergen it's a group of guys that talked
about what we went through growing up
and not Bergen on those hills there was
a hell 46th Street that was so steep
there was a cemetery on it and whatever
it rained it would wash the graves and
they'd be [ __ ] caskets on the bottom
of 46 feet
what DD that kid never saw it among
Carlos his older brother their mother
lived on that it was a dead end you know
me cars came down that thing crashed
against they happened they were growing
up Wow they would lose control and just
crash it was a [ __ ] huge yeah like
two miles momentum and we would walk up
that hill backwards talking with a beer
in our head uh-huh when we were kids
smoking a joint
well I just which grew for my buddies
think I would take this up to three
hours to walk up the hill now I'd have a
heart attack about it was upside down
yeah we would walk it three times a
night got a walk in the morning to get a
bus back down and then at night if you
want to go uptown you gotta walk it
again so we just get liquor and walk up
to hell drinking [ __ ] liquor so
whatever it rains in that neighborhood
D'Agostino the [ __ ] it would wash the
graves I'm gonna go first move in there
and people like you gotta run 246 Street
there's a guy in a casket you could see
like a skeleton and [ __ ] I was like what
and then later on I didn't see it but
later on when I started hanging out with
those two I asked him if those stories
returned he goes all the [ __ ] time
we've seen caskets bodies bones you know
a lot of because it's an old cemetery
like people were buried in 1830 oh wow
1890 19 you know like the the bob the
lower half yeah like it went up as the
years okay so the closer was to your
year you walk to hell but all those
people on the bottom or in the middle
were all like 1990 I'm gonna taking a
[ __ ] in there one night and the dead of
the winter and have those I felt guilty
I'm like I'm [ __ ] on the Grammys
guys that the relatives left like a
stick like was name like was just a
stick like the crosses crook like me
like Jesus had a long arm there the
other one like
like it's city slickers when they buried
them right yeah so I would take shits in
there all the time I couldn't make it
home in the summertime I just get three
[ __ ] pieces of grass wipe my ass walk
home a little dirty ass cheese enough to
make it home and there'd be no skid
marks any other way you just pull off
your pants and you could smell your ass
always felt dirty
so whenever with the handlebars so I
bring the [ __ ] bike home yeah and
next door to me I had this goofy kid
Valentin Farrow who will not be my
friend he refuses to be my friend he's a
[ __ ] dentist in Kentucky now one of
those places
I found them online I just went online
and pressed his name and there he was so
they won't accept your request is what
you're saying no I called his dental
office hmm they left a message like Coke
was on the line and she's like he
doesn't want to talk to you sir
Wow and I'm like okay and I [ __ ]
thought about why wouldn't you want to
talk to him like tortured this kid my
mistake not really like every time he
hung with me something bad happens not
because I was a bad person I loved I
loved he was a [ __ ] grease monkey he
was great but he was a speed demon you
know he was one of those killed that
builds ramps okay like way like as soon
as I moved to Jersey he was my neighbor
mm-hmm and he'd always be building him
and this kid Michael Clemons wet fleece
what do you call it when they have they
have lice lice the whole family having a
crew cuts ha ha ha ha so they were to
like bite junkies and they lived right
next door to each other
so I stir it like there was two wins
abut that one then we'll get the [ __ ]
out of here and when I bought that a
Power Eraser I came home but 6 months
before the Apollo racer
I bought a minibike Christmas Eve the
the lawnmower ones yeah and he [ __ ]
fell off and got stitches and [ __ ] cuz
the seat wasn't screwed on so every time
he'd see me he's like man that night
[ __ ] me up I ended up the hospital on
Christmas Eve so he was ok with me we
was friends and I loved him to death but
he was every time he'd see me when I
came home with the bike that day he's
like hey that's a
cool last bike man Wow cuz he was like a
half a bike thief so we would steal
bikes we bring them to him and he would
change him for us he popped the plate
off he would screw [ __ ] tape it he'd
sand the [ __ ] VIN number down oh I
put another one on it yeah like he was a
[ __ ] chief so if somebody saw you at
the bike and said hey man that's my bike
we talking about mm-hmm look at the VIN
just saying your bike and the guy would
be looking at this number look at the ha
it's not my bike huh sorry so we would
take a bike
what's a call when you prime it you take
the whole paint off yeah and put this
great thing on it would strip the old
paint off the metal then we'd sand it to
make a porous and then we paint them and
then we paint like two or three coats
and we put that other [ __ ] on it to
Silby stuff so nobody knows who bikes I
mean everybody well the stolen bike
brother Valentin so he was considered a
neighborhood [ __ ] mechanic okay
so I get home one day and he's like
there's window he's one of those kids
that had like the screen window the
window we would though like it was like
a storm windows yeah a windows he would
open up all is that the power racing
with you my thinking fur and come down
seek amazing man this is great
thank you I always wanted one of these
and that knock yourself out dog I had no
bad malice in my heart
he took the [ __ ] bike up the hill he
even did that thing we test the winner
oh my god and I'm sitting there and I
don't know what's got he's a great kid
he's gonna be fun but he's pedaling that
he got up on the bike you know when you
get up and you're really peddling but
the guy didn't tighten the screw for the
handlebars so the handlebars basically
went straight down he's looking I'm like
what the [ __ ] is this and all I seen it
was it's up his body man and he hadn't
talked to you since that time no oh that
was good we became in the still friends
that we got older we have him drinking
and smoking dope he was a great kid big
kid tough kid and one night we started
lighting fires in the woods really 13 14
a happy 13th we would light fires in the
woods and every night you would show up
with something so you'd show up with a
piece of paper to contribute to the fire
or a piece of wood or a little bit of
gasoline and a little bit of liquid you
know wow yeah yeah not him
guess what this [ __ ] shows up
with an industrial panel I saw like the
big man since 1970 when they were big
and thick and we already had the fire on
the fire was already gone he showed up
late he's like oh look what I got like
what the [ __ ] is that what are you gonna
do spray there's a lot of people would
spray that yeah you missed he throws the
whole can undo the whole we're like
what's gonna happen if I don't know what
stand of it and dog I don't know what it
was it was like slow motion I was kind
of looking at that you know when you
look at a fire you get intrigues yeah I
saw the thing explode at the bottom of
the can you know how it has the opal AHA
that little bump in the thing yeah I saw
that thing fly right off and it was like
something out of a [ __ ] movie so this
is the bottom of it yeah and they flew
off and once you had Jesus don't write
to him right through the [ __ ] jeans
you could smell the skin and he's like
ah he ran home we'll [ __ ] man one
time me my buddy who went to Grant High
School over here we used to ride our
bikes around and we found this apartment
you know sometimes the the floor
apartments they'll have furnish so they
can show people like before they rent it
so it's always here furnished we broke
in there one time and we made a murder
scene we got like red paint and made it
like blood and we put like a note like a
murder notes
and if they buy it I mean we didn't wait
around for people you gotta wait for
them you gotta make believe I can just
plant yeah we let them show up and what
let's get that bottom listed and then
you go over to tell him Frank excuse
I saw a Chinese guy with a bat walking
down the block at two o'clock a Chinese
guy he just give him fake information so
we even know we would lure do it yeah
wait for the cops to come and they were
go did you see anything oh yeah Jewish
guys I saw everything a black Hamid
Jewish and the guy was it was too hard
to believe you can see there was a real
pleasure seeing you and have you done I
don't want to make you feel bad
I got no dates either got dates you do I
got a date June 20th for the time being
yeah that's not a date you think it's
not gonna happen though where is it in a
Paso Robles oh yeah but how do you but a
different state
no Paso Robles California it's like an
hour drive listen bud nobody those Edda
brewery will see if it happens
nobody though stuff yeah nobody knows
nothing to the day out mm-hmm you know I
tell you I'm the type of [ __ ]
like I told you I will pass out of the
point yeah I am petrified that the plane
takes off and I go into panic mode and
then I gotta get pinned down like that
Chinese guy I would like to stand out
and I can't let that happen
yeah so for right now I'm gonna sit at
home for a few weeks I'll wait to the
store opens I'm not gonna run down there
fast either I'm gonna take my time I'm
gonna older [ __ ] man and I gotta
really I don't want to flip out no right
now yeah but listen man anytime you need
something you call it's great to see you
tell your family for me what time the
episode you do a week to two now comes
out on Tuesday and Friday okay
and I I released an album I'm tell you
what this time off I got a little bit of
stuff done I had an old
my record a couple years ago I never
released it I just submitted it for
distributing right now so it'll be out
soon and you guys can follow me on my
social media on my websites homeschooled
pod comm for all that stuff and we have
fun we have fun on the podcast it's good
thank you very much thank you and I'll
explain the homeschool cuz I'm [ __ ]
confused yeah me undies me undies beyond
these the best me on this is the world
show off this more sustainable
Underpants it's like having a [ __ ] a
hand holding your [ __ ] nuts all day
every day when you're rocking me undies
you understand me
the point is it's time to cut off your
toxic relationship when you're [ __ ]
old [ __ ] underwear make the adult
decision and get yourself a little
monthly plan for clean fresh and sloshed
skivvies listen we got manscape we got
me and E's I'm getting you ready to get
your dick sucked do you not see what
your uncle Joey's doing for you that's
all I want you to do that's all I want
for any of you people is to have a great
time and a great life and to look sharp
there's nothing like pulling your pants
off and the girl sees those white little
[ __ ] [ __ ] underwears we wore yellow
pee stain how would you feel would you
suck that dick if you saw a man with a
little yellow pee stain on his underwear
that's what I gotta put different colors
and then we'll see the [ __ ] beast and
make the adult decision alright
you'll never have to settle for [ __ ]
a pair of tighty whities again don't be
[ __ ] embarrassed get me on these
delivered straight to your door with
free shipping Dave they're designed to
be the softest thing you'll ever put on
your body thanks to the magic fabric
they call micro mode ow and they come in
all shapes sizes from extra small the
Forex or bodies or welcome me undies
doesn't just make undies they also have
loungewear and all the same from pilings
you'll love as the underpants listen to
me I've been dealing with me on these
for seven years they're the most
comfortable on the right there they keep
my balls in place and they just feel
[ __ ] great
I don't wear no along the way so do me a
favor
me and these will not stop till every
[ __ ] a single family church member
gets one so me and these has a great
offer for the church family you ready
any first-time purchases
you get 15% off and free shipping you
can't beat that this is a no-brainer
especially because they have 100%
satisfaction guarantee so do me a favor
I'm gonna give you 15% off your first
pair free shipping 100% money back
guarantee satisfaction guarantee go to
me on these dot-com / Joey
that's me undies dot Tom clothes last
Joey you're right 50% off free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee again go
to me on these slash Joey and I want to
thank me undies I want to thank the
Agostino order but most importantly I
want to thank you guys for a great week
listen I know it's tough for everybody
we'll try to do our best and that's all
that matters
I love your mother [ __ ] long my heart
I will see you guys Monday morning nice
and early tip top Magoo no drama one
more time follow the Agostino or don't
listen to his podcast homeschooled and
that's it and that's that I love you
[ __ ] don't forget about blue
chew and don't forget about me undies ly
kick this [ __ ] meal
[Music]